all right so who's ready for some more
category theory
um you're all in the wrong room
so this talk uh
i i hope seems uh deceptively obvious
uh
one of the things that's great about
this conference is this is a this is a
pretty cutting edge crowd a lot of you
are adopting new technologies a lot of
you are doing functional programming and
you may you may be nodding saying yeah
yeah through parts of this and
if some of it's familiar that that's
great
on the other hand i think that
i would hope that you would come away
from this talk with some tools you could
use
to help conduct a similar kind of
discussion to this talk with other
people
that you're trying to convince to do the
right thing
uh so
i'll start with an appeal to authority
um
simplicity is a prerequisite for
reliability i certainly agree with this
i don't agree with everything
dijkstra said and i i think he might
have been very wrong about proof in
particular but i think he's right about
this
we need to build simple systems if we
want to build good systems
and i don't think we focus enough on
that
i love word origins they're tremendous
fun
um one of the reasons why they're fun is
because words eventually become uh come
to mean whatever we all accept them to
mean you know whatever's commonly
understood to be the meaning is what it
means
and uh it's often interesting to say
well i wish i could i wish we'd go back
to what it really means
and use that and i think there's a
couple of words that i'm going to use in
this talk that i would love
for you to come away
knowing the origins of and try to use
more precisely especially when talking
about software
so the first word is simple
and the roots of this word are sim and
plex
and that means one fold or one braid or
twist
and that characteristic about being
about one
um
literally fold or twist of course one
twist hey what's one twist look like
no twists right actually
and it the opposite of this word is uh
complex
which means
braided together
or folded together
being able to think about our software
in terms of whether or not it's folded
together sort of the
central point of this talk
the other word
we frequently use interchangeably with
simple is the word easy
and the derivation there is to a french
word
and the last step of this derivation is
actually speculative but uh i bought it
because it serves this talk really well
and that is from the latin word that is
the root of adjacent
and which means to lie near
and to be nearby
and the opposite is hard of course the
root of heart has nothing to do with
lying there it doesn't mean lie far away
um
it actually means like strong
or torturously so
so if we want to try to apply simple to
the kinds of work that we do
um we're going to start with this
concept of having one braid
and
look at it in a few different dimensions
i thought it was interesting in eric's
talk to talk about dimensions because
it's definitely a big part of doing
design work
and so if we want to look for simple
things we want to look for things that
have sort of one of something they do
they have one role
they fulfill one task or job they're
about accomplishing sort of one
objective
uh they might be about one concept
like security
um
and
and sort of overlapping with that is
they may they may be about a particular
dimension of the problem that you're
trying to solve
the critical thing there though is that
when you're looking for something simple
you want to see it have focus
in these areas
you don't want to see it
combining things
on the other hand we can't get too
fixated about uh one
in particular simple doesn't mean uh
that there's only one of them
right uh it also doesn't mean
um an interface that only has one
operation
so it's important to distinguish
uh
cardinality right counting things
from actual interleaving what matters
for simplicity is that there's there's
no interleaving not that there's only
one thing
and that's very important
uh
okay
the other critical thing about simple as
we've just described it
right is if something is interleaved or
not
that's sort of an objective thing
you can probably go and look and see i
don't see any connections i don't see
anywhere where this twist was something
else
so simple is actually an objective
notion
that's also very important in deciding
the difference between simple and easy
so let's look at easy
i think this notion of nearness is
really really cool
in particular
obviously there's many ways in which
something can be near
right there's sort of the physical
notion of being near
right is something
uh
you know like right there and i think
that's where the root of the word came
from you know this is easy to obtain
because it's it's nearby it's not in the
next town i don't have to take a horse
or
whatever to go get to it we don't have
the same notion of physicality
necessarily in our software um but we do
sort of have
you know our own hard drive or our own
tool set
or sort of the ability to make things
physically near by getting them
through things like installers and stuff
like that
the second notion of nearness is
something being near to our
understanding
right or in our current skill set and
i don't mean in this case near to our
understanding meaning a capability i
mean literally near something that we
already know
uh so the word the word in this case is
is about being familiar
i think that uh collectively we are
infatuated with these two notions of
easy we are just so
self-involved in these two aspects it's
hurting us tremendously right all we
care about is you know can i get this
instantly and start running it in five
seconds
it could be this giant hairball that you
got but all you care is you can you get
it
in addition we're fixated on oh i can't
i can't read that
i can't read german does that mean
german is unreadable
no
i don't know german
so you know this this sort of approach
is is definitely not helpful in
particular if you want everything to be
familiar you will never learn anything
new because it can't be significantly
different from what you already know and
not drift away from the familiarity
there's a third aspect of being easy uh
that i don't think we think enough about
that's going to become critical to this
discussion which is which now is
being near to our capabilities
and we don't like to talk about this
because it makes us uncomfortable
because what kind of capabilities are we
talking about if we're talking about
easy in the case of violin playing or
piano playing or mountain climbing or
something like that
well you know
i don't personally feel bad if i don't
play the violin well because i don't
play the violin at all
but the work that we're in is conceptual
work so when we start talking about
something being outside of our
capability we'll you know it really
starts trampling on our egos in a big
way um
and so you know due to a
a combination of hubris and insecurity
we never really talk about whether or
not something is outside of our
capabilities it ends up that
um
it's not so embarrassing after all
because we don't have tremendously
divergent abilities in that area
uh the last thing i want to say about
easy
and the critical thing to distinguish it
from simple is that easy is relative
right playing the violin and reading
german are really hard for me
they're easy for other people certain
other people
so unlike simple where we can go and
look for interleavings look for braiding
easy is always going to be you know easy
for whom
or hard for whom
it's a relative term
uh the fact that we throw these things
around sort of casually saying oh i like
to use that technology because it's
simple and when i'm saying simple i mean
easy and when i'm saying easy i mean
because i already know something that
looks very much like that is how this
whole thing degrades and we can never
have an objective
discussion about the qualities
that matter to us in our software
so
what's one critical area where we that
where we have to distinguish these two
things uh
and uh
and look at them from uh perspective of
them being easy and being simple
it is it has to do with constructs and
artifacts
right we program with constructs we have
programming languages we use particular
libraries and uh those things in and of
themselves when we look at them like
when we look at the code we write have
certain characteristics in and of
themselves
but we're in a business of artifacts
right we don't ship source code and the
user doesn't look at our source code and
say oh that's so pleasant
right no
they run our software and they run it
for a long period of time and over time
we keep bloming more stuff on our
software
all that stuff the running of it
the performance of it the ability to
change it all is an attribute of the
artifact
not the original construct
but again
here we still focus so much on our
experience of the use of the construct
oh look i only had to type 16 characters
wow that's great
no semicolons or things like that
this whole notion of sort of program or
convenience again we are infatuated with
it
not not to our benefit
on the flip side it gets even worse our
employers are also infatuated with them
right those first two meanings of easy
what do they mean
right if i can get another programmer in
here
right and
they look at your source code and they
think it's familiar
right
and uh they already know the toolkit
right so it's near at hand they've
always had the same tool in their
toolkit they can read it
i can replace you
it's a breeze especially if i ignore the
third notion of easy
right which is whether or not anybody
can understand your code
right because that they don't actually
care about that they're just because
somebody can go sit in your seat start
typing
so again as sort of uh business owners
um there's sort of an again the same
kind of focus on those first two aspects
of easy because it makes programmers
replaceable
so we're gonna we're gonna contrast this
with the impacts of long-term use
right
uh what does it mean to use this long
term
and uh
what what's there what's there is all
the meat
right does the software do what it's
supposed to do
um
is it of high quality can we rely on it
doing what it's supposed to do
can we
fix problems when they arise and if
we're given a new requirement can we
change it
these things have nothing to do
with the construct as we typed it in
or very little to do with it and have a
lot to do with
the attributes of the artifact
we have to start assessing our
constructs based around the artifacts
not around the look and feel of the
experience of typing it in
or the cultural aspects of that
so
let's talk a little bit about limits oh
look it does move
this is just supposed to sort of lull
you into this
state where everything i say seems true
because i can't use monads to do that
uh
this stuff is pretty simple logic right
how can we possibly make things that are
reliable that we don't understand
right it's very very difficult
i think
professor sussman made a great point
saying there's going to be this
trade-off right as we make things more
flexible and extensible and dynamic
in some possible futures for some kinds
of systems we are going to make a
trade-off in our ability to to
understand their their behavior and make
sure that they're correct
but for the things that we want to
understand and and make sure are correct
we're going to be limited
uh we're going to limit our
understanding and our understanding is
is very limited right there's a whole
notion of you know how many how many
balls can you keep in the air at the
time or how many things can you keep in
mind at a time it's a it's a limited
number and it's a very small number
right so we can only consider a few
things and when things are intertwined
together we lose the ability to take
them in isolation so if every time i
think i pull out a new part of
the software i need to comprehend and
it's attached to another thing i have to
pull that other thing into my mind
because i can't think about the one
without the other that's the nature of
them being intertwined so every
intertwining
is adding this burden and the burden is
kind of combinatorial
as to the number of things that we can
we can consider so fundamentally
this complexity and by complexity i mean
just braiding together of things
is going to limit our ability to
understand our systems
so
so how do we change our software
apparently i heard in the talk today
that agile and extreme programming have
shown that refactoring and tests
allow us to make a change with zero
impact
i never knew that
i still do not know that
because
that's not actually a knowable thing
it's that's phooey
right if you're going to change software
you're going to need to analyze what it
does and make decisions about what it
ought to do
yeah i mean at least you're going to
have to go and say what is the impact of
this potential change
right and
what parts of the software do i need to
go to to effect the change
and you know i don't
i don't care if using xp or agile or
anything else you're not going to get
around the fact that if you can't reason
about your program you can't make these
decisions
um
but i do want to make clear here because
a lot of people as soon as they hear the
word reason about they're like oh my god
are you saying that you have to be able
to prove programs i am not i don't
believe in that i don't think that's an
objective i'm just talking about
informal reasoning the same kind of
reasoning we use every day to decide
what we're going to do we do not take
out category theory and
say you know
we actually can reason without it
thank goodness
so what about what about the other side
right there's two things you do with the
future of your software one is you add
new capabilities the other thing is you
fix the ones you didn't get you know so
you know done so well
uh and i like to ask this question
what's true of every bug found in the
field
it got written yes
what's the more interesting fact about
it
it passed the type checker
what else did it do
it passed all the tests
okay
so now what do you do
right i i think we're in this world
uh
i'd like to call guardrail programming
right
it's really sad we're like i can make
change because i have tests
right who does that who drives their car
around banging against the guard rail
saying whoa
i'm glad i've got these guard rails
because i'd never make it to uh to the
show on time
right
and
and um do the guardrails head help you
get to where you want to go
like do guard rails like guide you
places
no there's guardrails everywhere they
don't point your car in any particular
direction
so
again we're going to need to be able to
think about our program it's going to be
critical all of our guardrails will will
have failed us we're going to have this
problem we're going to need to be able
to reason about our program say well you
know what i think
because maybe if it's not too complex
i'll be able to say i know through
ordinary logic
it couldn't be in this part of the
program it must be in that part and let
me go look there first
things like that
now of course everybody's going to start
moaning but i have all this speed i'm
agile i'm fast
i you know this easy stuff is making my
life good because i i have a lot of
speed
so what kind of runner
can run as fast as they possibly can
from the very start of a race
right only somebody who runs really
short races
okay
but of course we are programmers and
we're smarter than runners apparently
because we know how to fix that problem
right we just fire the starting pistol
every 100 yards and call it a new sprint
i
[Applause]
i don't know why they haven't figured
that out but
right
it's my contention
based on experience
that if you ignore complexity you will
slow down you will invariably slow down
over the long haul
of course if you are doing something
that's really short term you don't need
any of this you could write it you know
in ones and zeros
and this is my really scientific graph
you notice how none of the axes are
there's no numbers on it
because i just i completely made it up
um
it's a it's an experiential graph and
what it shows is
if you focus on ease
and not and ignore simplicity so i'm not
saying you can't try to do both that
would be great but if you focus on ease
you will be able to go as fast as
possible from the beginning of the race
but no matter what technology you use or
sprints or firing pistols or whatever
the complexity will eventually kill you
it will kill you in a way that will make
every sprint accomplish less most
sprints be about completely redoing
things you've already done
and the net effect is you're not moving
forward in any significant way now if
you start by focusing on simplicity why
can't you go as fast as possible
right at the beginning
because some some tools that are simple
are actually as easy to use as some
tools that are not
why can't you go as fast then
you have to think you have to actually
apply some simplicity work to the
problem before you start and that's
going to give you this ramp up
so one of the problems i think we have
is this conundrum that some things that
are easy
actually are are complex so let's look
um there are a bunch of um constructs
that have complex artifacts that are
very succinctly described right some of
the things that are really dangerous to
use are like so simple to describe
they're incredibly familiar right if
you're coming from object orientation
you're familiar with a lot of complex
things they're very much available
right
and they're easy to use in fact by all
measures conventional measures you would
look at them and say this is easy
right but we don't care about that right
again the user's not looking at our
software and they don't actually care
very much about how good a time we had
when we were writing it
right what they care about is what the
program does
and the and if it works well it will be
related to whether or not
the output of those constructs more
simple in other words what what
complexity do they yield
when there is complexity there
we're going to call that incidental
complexity right it wasn't part of what
the user asked us to do we chose the
tool it had some inherent complexity in
it it's incidental to the problem i
didn't put the definition in here
but
incidental is latin for your fault
and it is and i think you really have to
ask yourself you know are you
programming with a loom
you know you're having a great time
you're throwing that shuttle back and
forth and what's coming out the other
side is this
knotted you know mess i mean it may look
pretty
but you have this problem
right where's the problem the problem is
the knitted castle problem
right
do you want a knitted castle
so what what benefits do we do we get
from simplicity we get ease of
understanding right that's sort of
definitional
i contend we get ease of change
and easier debugging
other benefits that come out of it that
are sort of on a secondary level are
increased flexibility and when we talk
more about modularity and breaking
things apart we'll see where they where
that falls
like the ability to
[Music]
change policies or move things around
right as we make things simpler we get
more independence of decisions
because they're not interleaved so i can
make a location decision it's orthogonal
from
like a performance decision
um and i really do want to make you know
ask the question
agilist or whatever
is is having a test suite
and refactoring tools going to make
changing the knitted castle faster
than changing the lego castle
no way
completely unrelated
okay
so how do we make things easy presumably
you know the objective here is not to
just bemoan
this the software crisis right so what
can we do to make things easier so we'll
look at those parts those aspects of
being easy again there's a location
aspect
making something at hand putting it in
our toolkit that's relatively simple
right we just install it
right maybe it's a little bit harder
because we have to get somebody to say
it's okay to use it
then there's the aspect of how do i make
it familiar right i may not have ever
seen this before that's a learning
exercise i've got to go get a book go
take a tutorial have somebody explain it
to me maybe try it out
right both these things are we're
driving we're driving we install we
learn we're it's totally in our hands
then we have this other part though
right which is the mental capability
part
and there's a part that's always hard to
talk about the mental capability part uh
right because the fact is
we can learn more things we actually
can't get much smarter
we're not going to move
we're not going to move our brain closer
to the complexity
um
we have to make things nearby
simplifying them the the but the truth
here is not that like they're these
super super
you know bright people who can do these
amazing things and everybody else is
stuck
because the juggling analogy is pretty
close
right the average juggler can do three
balls the most amazing juggler in the
world can do like nine balls or 12 or
something like that they can't do 20 or
100
right all of we're all very limited
you know compared to the complexity we
can create we're all you know
statistically at the same point in our
ability to understand it which is not
very good
so we're going to have to bring things
towards us
and because we can only juggle so many
balls you have to make a decision how
many of those balls
do you want to be incidental complexity
and how many do you want to be problem
complexity
all right how many extra balls you want
to have somebody throwing your balls
that you have to try to incorporate in
here oh use this tool and you're like
whoa
you know more more stuff who wants to do
that
all right so let's look at a
let's look at a fact
so i've been on the other side of this
complaint
and
i like it we can look at it really
quickly um only because uh
it it's not this analysis has nothing to
do with the usage this complexity
analysis is just about the programmer
experience
right so parens are hard
right they're not at hand for most
people who haven't otherwise used it and
what does that mean it means that like
um
uh they don't have an editor that knows
how to do you know paren matching or
move stuff around structurally or they
have one and they've never loaded the
mode that makes that happen
totally given
right it's not at hand
nor is it familiar i mean everybody's
seen parentheses but they haven't seen
them on that side of the method
i mean
that is just crazy
uh
but you know i think this this is your
responsibility right to fix these two
things as a user as a potential user you
got to do this
but we could dig deeper let's look at
the third thing did you actually give me
something that was simple is a language
built all out of parens
simple
in the case i'm saying right is it free
of interleaving and braiding and the
answer is no
right common lispen scheme
are not simple in this sense in their
use of parens because the use of
parentheses in those languages is
overloaded
right parens
wrap calls they wrap
grouping
they wrap data structures
right and that overloading is a form of
complexity by the definition of you know
i gave you
right
and so if you actually bothered to get
your editor set up and learn that the
parenthesis goes on the other side of
the verb
this was still a valid complaint now of
course everybody was saying easy it's
hard it's complex and they were using
these words really weekly right but it
was hard for a couple of reasons you
could solve and it was not simple for a
reason that was the fault of the
language designer which was that there
was overloading there right and we can
fix that
right we can just add another data
structure it doesn't make lisp not lisp
to have more data structures
right it's still a language defined in
terms of its own data structures
but having more data structures in play
means that we can get rid of this
overloading in this case
which then makes it your fault again
right because now this the simplicity is
back in the construct and it's just a
familiarity thing which you can solve
for yourself
okay
um this is an old dig
at list programmers i i i'm not
totally sure what the um what he was
talking about i believe it was a
performance related thing the whispers
were just they conceded up all this
memory and they did all this evaluation
and it was it was a pig list programs at
that time were list programs at that
time were complete pigs relative to the
hardware um so they you know they knew
the value of all these constructs right
this dynamis you know dynamic nature
these things are all great they are
valuable
right but there was this performance
cost
i'd like to lift this whole phrase and
apply it to all of us right now right as
programmers we are looking at all kinds
of things and i just see it you know
read hacker news or whatever it's like
oh look this thing has this benefit oh
great i'm gonna do that oh but this has
this benefit oh that's cool
oh that's awesome you know that's
shorter
never
see in these discussions was there a
trade-off is there any downside you know
is there anything bad that comes along
with this never nothing it's just like
we look all for benefits right so as
programmers now i think we're looking
all for benefits and we're not looking
carefully enough at the
byproducts
so
what's in your toolkit
i have a you know
i have these two columns one says
complexity and one says simplicity
the simplicity column uh just means
simpler
it doesn't mean that the things over
there are purely simple
now i didn't label these things bad and
good
i'm leaving
your minds to do that
[Laughter]
so what what things are complex and what
are the simple replacements i'm going to
dig into the details on these so i won't
actually explain why they're complex
we're going to say state and objects are
complex
and values are simple
and and can replace them in many cases
i'm going to say methods are complex
and functions are simple and namespaces
are simple
the reason why methods are there because
often the space of methods on the class
or whatever is also a mini very poor
namespace
vars
are complex and variables are complex
managed references are also complex but
they're simpler
inheritance switch statements pattern
matching are all complex and
polymorphism a la carte is simple
okay now remember the meaning of simple
the meaning of simple means unentangled
right not twisted together with
something else
doesn't mean i already know what it
means
right simple does that mean i already
know what it means
okay
syntax is complex data is simple
imperative loops fold even which seems
kind of higher level still has some
implications that tie two things
together whereas set functions are
simpler
actors are complex
and queues are simpler
orm is
complex and declarative data
manipulation is simpler okay even eric
said that in his talk he said it really
fast near the end
oh yeah an eventual consistency is
really hard for programmers
conditionals are complex in interesting
ways and rules can be can be simpler
and inconsistency is very complex it's
almost definitionally complex right
because consistent means to stand
together so inconsistent means to stand
apart and that means taking a set of
things that are standing apart and
trying to think about them all at the
same time
it's inherently complex to do that and
anybody who's tried to use the system
that's eventually consistent knows that
okay
so there's this really cool word
called complex
i found it
i love it it means to interleave or
entwine or braid
okay um i want to start talking about
what we do to our software that makes it
bad
i don't want to say braid or entwine
because it doesn't really have the good
bad connotation that complex has complex
is obviously bad
right
it happens to be an archaic word but you
know there's no rules that say you can't
start using them again so i'm going to
use them for the rest of the talk
so what do you know about complex it's
bad
don't do it right
this is where complexity comes from
right complecting
that's very simple
right and in particular it's something
you want to avoid in the first place
right look at this diagram
look at the first one
look at the last one
right it's the same stuff in both those
diagrams the exact it's the same strips
what happened
they got complected
and now it's hard to understand the
bottom
diagram from the top one but it's the
same stuff
you're doing this all the time you can
make a program a hundred different ways
some of them it's just hanging there
it's all straight you look at it you say
oh i see it's four lines this program
right then you could type in four lines
in another language or with a different
construct and you end up with this knot
so we've got to take care of that
so um complex actually means to braid
together
and compose means to place together
and we know that right everybody keeps
telling us what we want to do is make
composable systems we just want to place
things together
which is great and i think there's no
disagreement right composing simple
components simple in that same
respect is the way we write
robust software
so
it's simple right all we need to do is
everybody knows this i'm up here just
telling you stuff you know we can make
simple systems by making them modular
right
we're done
i'm like halfway through my talk i don't
even know if i'm going to finish it's so
simple
right this is it this is the key
no it's obviously not the key
right who has seen who has seen
components that have this kind of
characteristic
i'll read my hand twice because not
enough people are raising their hands
it's ridiculous right what happens you
can write modular software with all
kinds of interconnections between them
right they may not call each other
but they're completely complected
right and we know how to solve this it
it has nothing to do with the fact that
there are two things it has to do with
what those two things are allowed to
think about if you want to really
anthropomorphize and what do we want to
make things allowed to think about
and only these things
some abstractions i don't know if that's
coming out that well
that's a a dashed white version of the
top of the lego
right that's all we want to limit things
to because now the blue guy doesn't
really know anything about the yellow
ground the yellow guy doesn't really
know anything about the blue guy and
they both become simple
so it's very it's very important that
you don't associate simplicity with
partitioning and stratification right
they don't imply it
right they are enabled by it if you make
simple components you can horizontally
um separate them and you can vertically
stratify them right but you can also do
that with complex things and you're
going to get no benefits and so i would
encourage you to be particularly careful
not to
be fooled by code organization
right there's tons of libraries that
look oh look there's different classes
they're separate classes they you know
they call each other in sort of these
nice ways right then you get out in the
field and you're like oh my god this
thing presumes that that thing never
returns the number 17.
what is that
okay
i'm not going to get up here and tell
you state is awesome i like state i'm
not a functional whatever guy whatever
i'm going to say instead
i did this
and it sucked
right i did years and years c plus
you know he-man
stateful programming
it's it's really not fun
it's not good
um
it's it's never simple having state in
your program is never simple
right because it has a fundamental
complexing that goes on in its artifacts
right it complex value and time you
don't have the ability to get a value
independent of of time and
sometimes not an ability to get a value
in any proper sense at all
but again it's a great example this is
easy it's totally familiar it's at hand
it's in all the programming languages
this is so easy this complexity is so
easy
and you can't get rid of it everything
so i'll have i have modularity that that
assignment statement is inside a method
right well if if every time you call
that method with the same arguments you
can get a different result guess what
happened
that complexity just leaked right out of
there it doesn't matter that you can't
see the variable
right if the thing that's wrapping it is
stateful the thing that's wrapping that
is still stateful in other words by
staple i mean every time you ask it the
same question you get a different answer
you have this complexity and it's like
poison
it's like dropping you know some some
dark liquid into this to a boss it's
just going to end up all over the place
the only time you can really you know
get rid of it is when you put it inside
something that's able to present a
functional interface on the outside a
true functional interface same input
same output
you can't mitigate it
through the ordinary code organization
things
and note in particular i didn't talk
about concurrency here this is not about
concurrency this has nothing to do with
concurrency has it it's about your
ability to understand your program your
program was out there it's single
threaded it didn't work all the tests
passed it made it through the type
checker
figure out what happened right if it's
full of variables what are you going to
need to try to do
recreate the state that was happening at
the client when it went bad
is that going to be easy
no
but we fixed this right your language
your new shiny language has something
called var
or maybe has uh refs or references
none of these constructs make states
simple that's the first primary thing i
don't want to say that even of closures
constructs they do not make states
simple in the case i'm talking about in
the nature of simple i'm talking about
but they're not the same
right they all do warn you when you have
state and that's great most people who
are using a language where immutability
is not the default you have to go out of
your way to get it finds that the
programs they end up writing have
dramatically like
orders of magnitude less state than they
would otherwise because they never
needed all the other state in the first
place
so that's really great
but i will call out closure and
haskell's references as being
particularly superior in dealing with
this because they compose values and
time they're actually little constructs
that do two things they have some
abstraction over time and the ability to
extract a value
that's really important
because that's that's your path back to
simplicity
if i have a way to get out of this thing
and get a value out i can continue with
my program after i pass that variable to
somebody else or a reference to
something that's going to find the
variable every time through the varying
thing
i'm poisoning the rest of my system
so uh
you know look at the var in your
language and ask if it does the same the
same thing
all right let's see why things are uh
complex state we already talked about it
complexed everything it touches
objects complex
state identity and value they mix these
three things up in a way that you cannot
extricate the parts
methods complex function and state
ordinarily
right in addition in some languages they
complex name spaces right derived from
two things in java they have the same
name method
right doesn't work
syntax interestingly
complex meaning and order often in a
very unidirectional way
professor sussman made the great point
about
data
versus syntax and you know it's super
true i don't care how much you really
love the syntax of your favorite
language it's inferior to data in every
way
inheritance complex types right it says
these two types are complected that's
what it means inheritance conflicting
it's like it's it's definitional
right switching and matching right they
complect multiple
pairs of who's going to do something and
what happens
right and they do it all in one place
in a closed way
that's very bad
vars and variables again complex value
and time often in an inextricable way so
you can't obtain a value we saw a
picture
during a keynote yesterday of this
amazing memory right where you could
de-reference
an address and get an object out
i want to get one of those computers
right have you ever used one of those
computers
i can't get one i called apple and they
were like
no
the only thing you can never get out of
a memory dress is a word a scalar
right the thing that was all derided
right recovering a composite object from
an address it's not something computers
do
none of the ones that we have
so variables have the same problem you
cannot recover a composite mutable thing
with with one dereference
um loops and fold
loops are pretty obviously
complecting what you're doing and how to
do it
fold is a little bit more subtle right
because it seems like this nice somebody
else is taking care of it but it does
have this implication about the order of
things this left to right bit
actors complete what's going to be done
and who's going to do it
now um
professor sussman said all these talks
have acronyms and i couldn't actually
modify my slides in time so object
relational mapping um has oh my god
complecting going on
you can't even begin to talk about how
how bad it is right and and and you know
if you're gonna do like um
uh
duels right
what's the dual of value
is it co-value what's a co-value
it's an inconsistent thing
who wants that and conditionals i think
are interesting right this is this is
sort of a more cutting edge area we have
a bunch of sort of rules about what our
program's supposed to do it's strewn all
throughout the program
can we fix that because that's
conflicted with the structure of the
program and the organization of the
program
all right
so if you take away two things from the
stock
one would be the difference between the
word simple and easy
the other i would hope
would be the fact that we can create
precisely the same
programs we're creating right now with
these tools of complexity with
dramatically drastically simpler tools
right i did c plus plus for a long time
i did java i did c sharp
i know how to make big systems in those
languages and i completely believe
you do not need all that complexity you
can write as sophisticated a system with
dramatically simpler tools which means
you're going to be focusing on the
system what it's supposed to do instead
of all the [ __ ] that
falls out of the construct you're using
so i'd love to say the first step in
getting a simpler life is to just choose
simpler stuff
right so if you want values usually you
can get it most languages have something
like values final or or val
you know lets you like declare something
as being immutable you do want to find
some persistent collections because the
harder thing in a lot of languages is
getting um
aggregates that are values
right you got to find a good library for
that or use the language where that's
the default
functions most languages have them thank
goodness
if you don't know what they are they're
like stateless methods
namespaces is something you really need
the language to do for you and
unfortunately it's not done very well
in a lot of places data please
we're programmers we supposedly write
data processing programs there's all
these programs they don't have any data
in them they have all these
constructs we put around it and globbed
on top of data data is actually really
simple there's not there's not a
tremendous number of variations in the
essential nature of data right there are
maps there are sets there are linear
sequential things there's not a lot of
other conceptual categories of data we
create hundreds of thousands of
variations that nothing to do with the
essence of the stuff and make it hard to
write programs that manipulate the
essence of this stuff we should just
manipulate the essence of the stuff it's
not hard it's simpler
also same thing for communications right
are we all not glad we don't use the
unix method of communicating on the web
right
any arbitrary command string can be the
argument list for your program and any
arbitrary set of characters can come out
the other end let's all write parsers
no i mean it's a problem it's it's a
source of complexity right so we can get
rid of that just use data
the biggest thing i think the most
desirable thing the most esoteric this
is tough to get but boy when you have it
your life is completely totally
different thing is polymorphism a la
carte
right closure protocols and haskell type
classes
and and constructs like that
give you the ability to independently
say i have data structures i have
definitions of sets of functions and i
can connect them together and those are
three independent operations
in other words the genericity is not
tied to anything in particular
it's available a la carte
i don't know of a lot of library
solutions for languages that don't have
it already talked about managed
references and how to get them maybe you
can use
closures from different java languages
set functions you can get from libraries
cues you can get from libraries right
you don't need a special communication
language you can get declarative data
manipulation by using sql or learning
sql
finally
or something like link or something like
data log i think these last couple of
things are harder right we don't have a
lot of ways to do this well integrated
with our languages i think uh currently
link is an is an effort to do that uh
rules right declarative rule systems
instead of you know embedding a bunch of
conditionals in our raw language at
every point of decision it's nice to
sort of gather that stuff and put it
over
someplace else and you can get rule
systems in libraries or you can use
languages like prolog if you want
consistency you need to use transactions
and you need to use values
okay there are reasons why you might
have to get off of this list but boy
there's no reason why you shouldn't
start with it
okay
there's a source of complexity that's
really difficult to deal with
and not your fault
i call it environmental complexity right
our programs end up running on machines
next to other programs next to other
parts of themselves and uh they contend
they contend for stuff
right memory cpu cycles and things like
that
everybody's contending for it this is an
inherent complexity
inherent is latin for not your fault
in the implementation space you know
this is not part of the problem
but it is part of the implementation
right you can't go back to the customer
and say the thing you wanted is not good
because um i have gc problems
uh but did you see problems and stuff
like that they come into play um there's
not a lot of great solutions right you
can do segmentation you can say this is
your memory this is your memory this is
your memory this is your your cpu and
your cpu but there's tremendous waste in
that right because you pre-allocate you
don't use everything you don't have sort
of dynamic nature
but the problem i think we're facing and
it's not one for which i have a solution
at the moment is that the policies
around this stuff don't compose
right if everybody says i'll just size
my thread pool to be the number of you
know of course
how many times can you do that in one
program
not a lot and have it still work out
so
unfortunately a lot of things like that
splitting that stuff up
and making an individual decision is not
actually making things simpler it's
making things complex because that's a
decision that needs to be made by
someone who has better information
and i don't think we have a lot of good
sources for
organizing those decisions in single
places in our systems
this is hugely long quote
basically it says programming is not
about typing
like this
it's about thinking
um so the next phase here i got to move
a little bit quicker is uh how do we
design simple things of our own right so
the first part of making things simple
is just to choose constructs that have
simple
artifacts but we have to write our own
constructs sometimes so how do we
abstract for simplicity
right an abstract again here's
an actual definition not made up one
means to draw something away and in
particular it means to draw away from
the physical nature of something
i do want to distinguish this from that
sometimes people use this term really
grossly to just mean hiding stuff
that is not what abstraction is and
that's not going to help you
in this space
there's two
you know i can't totally explain how
this is done it's really the job of
designing but one approach you can take
is just to do who what when where why
and how if you just go through those
things and sort of look at everything
you're deciding to do and say what is
the who aspect of this what is the what
aspect of it this can help you
take stuff apart
the other thing is to maintain this
approach that says i don't know i don't
want to know
i once said that so often during a c
plus plus course i was teaching that one
of the students made me a shirt
it was it was a booch diagram because we
didn't have uh
whatever it is now the unified one
and every line just said that
that's what you want to do you really
just don't want to know
all right so what is what um what is the
operations you know what what is what is
it what we want to accomplish
right we're going to form abstractions
by taking functions or more particularly
sets of functions and giving them names
in particular so and you're going to use
whatever your language lets you use
right so if you only have um interfaces
you'll use that if you have proto
protocols or type classes you'll use
those so all those things are in the
category of the things you use to make
sets of functions that are going to be
abstractions and they're really sets of
specifications of functions
the point i'd like to get across today
is just that they should be really small
much smaller than what we typically see
java interfaces are huge
and the reason why they are huge is
because java doesn't have union types so
it's inconvenient to say this function
takes you know something that does this
and that and that
you have to make this and that and that
interface so we see these giant
interfaces and the thing with those
giant interfaces is that it's a lot
harder to break up those programs
so you're going to represent them with
your polymorphism constructs they're
specifications
right they're not actually the
implementations
they should only use values and other
abstractions in their definitions so
you're going to define interfaces or
whatever type classes that only take
interfaces and type classes or
values
and return them and the biggest problem
you have when you're doing this part of
design is if you complete this with how
right you can complect it with how by
jamming them together and saying here's
just a concrete function instead of
having an interface or here's a concrete
class instead of having an interface you
can also complect it with how more
subtly by having some implication of the
semantics of the function dictate how it
is done
unfold is an example of that
strictly separating what from how is the
key to making how somebody else's
problem
right if you've done this really well
you can you can pawn off the work of
hell on somebody else you can say
database engine you figure out how to do
this thing or logic engine you figure
out how to search for this i i don't
need to know
who is about like data or entities these
are the things that abstraction is going
to be connected to eventually depending
on how your technology works
you want to build components up from sub
components in a sort of direct injection
style right you don't want to like
hardwire what the sub components are you
want to as much as possible take them as
arguments because that's going to give
you more programmatic flexibility in how
you build things
you should have probably many more sub
components than you have so you want
really much smaller interfaces than you
have and you want to have more sub
components than you probably are
typically having because usually you
have none and then maybe you have one
when you decide oh i need to farm out
policy if you go in saying this is a job
and i've done who what when where why
and i found five components
don't feel bad that's great you're
winning massively by doing that
you know split out policy and stuff like
that
and uh the thing that you have to uh be
aware of when you're building you know
the definition of a thing from sub
components is any any of those kind of
you know red yellow thinking about blue
blue thinking about yellow kind of
hidden detailed dependencies
so you want to avoid that
how things happen this is the actual
implementation code the work of of doing
the job
you you strictly want to connect these
things together using those polymorphism
constructs that's the most powerful
thing yeah you can use a switch
statement you could use pattern matching
but it's glomming all this stuff
together if you use one of these systems
you have an open
polymorphism policy
and that is really powerful especially
if it's run time
open but even if it's not it's better
than nothing
again beware of abstractions that
dictate how in some subtle way because
when you do that you really you're
nailing the person down the line who has
to do the implementation you're tying
their hands
so the more declarative things are the
better the better things work
and the thing that uh i mean how is sort
of the bottom
right don't mix this up with anything
else all these implementations should be
islands
as much as possible
when and where this is pretty simple i
think you just have to strenuously avoid
complexing this with anything
i see it accidentally coming in
mostly when people design systems with
directly connected objects right so if
you know the your program is architected
such that you know this thing um deals
with the input and then this thing has
to do the the next part of the job well
if if thing a
calls thing b
you just complected it
right and now you have a when and where
thing because now a has to know where b
is
in order to call b and um when that
happens is whenever a does it
right stick a q in there
right q's are the way to just get rid of
this problem if you're not using cues
extensively you should be you should
start right away
like right after this talk
and then there's the y part this is sort
of the policy and rules um this is a
this is i think this is hard for us
we typically put this stuff all over our
application and if you ever have to talk
to a customer about what the application
does you it's really difficult to sit
you know with them in source code and
look at it now if you have one of these
pretend testing systems that let you
write english strings so the customer
can look at that that's just silly right
you should have code that does the work
that somebody can look at which means to
try to you know
put this stuff someplace outside try to
find a declarative system or a rule
system will let you let you do this work
finally in this area information it is
simple right the only thing you can
possibly do with information is ruin it
right
don't do it
right don't do this stuff we i mean we
got objects objects were made to like
encapsulate io devices so there's a
screen but i can't like touch the screen
so i have the object right there's a
mouse i can't touch the mouse so there's
an object right that's all they're good
for they were never supposed to be
applied to information and we apply them
to information that's it's just wrong
it's wrong and but i can now say it's
wrong for a reason right it's wrong
because it's complex
in particular it ruins your ability to
build generic data manipulation things
if you leave data alone
right you can build things once that
manipulate data
and you can reuse them all over the
place and you know they're right once
and you're done
the other thing about it which also
applies to orm is that it will tie your
logic to representational things which
again tying complecting intertwining
so represent data as data please start
using maps and sets directly don't feel
like i have to write a class now because
i have a new piece of information it's
just silly
um
so the final aspect right so we
choose simple tools we
write simple stuff
and then sometimes we have to simplify
other people's stuff in particular we we
may have to simplify the problem space
or some code that somebody else wrote
this is a whole separate talk i'm not
going to get into right now
but the job is essentially one of
disentangling right we know what's
what's complex it's entangled so what do
we need to do
right we need to somehow disentangle it
right you're going to get this
you're going to need to first sort of
figure out
where it's going
you're going to have to follow stuff
around and eventually
label everything
right this is the start this is roughly
what the process is like but again it's
a whole separate talk to try to talk
about simplification
all right
i'm going to wrap up a couple of slides
the bottom line is simplicity is a
choice it's your fault if you don't have
a simple system
and and i think we have a culture of
complexity to the extent we all continue
to use these tools that have complex
outputs we're just in a rut we're just
self-reinforcing and we have to get out
of that rut but again like i said if
you're already saying i know this i
believe you i already use something
better i've already used that whole
right column then hopefully this talk
will give you the basis for talking with
somebody else who doesn't believe you
right talk about
simplicity versus complexity right but
it is a choice
right it requires constant vigilance we
already saw the guard rails don't yield
simplicity they don't really help us
here
right
it requires sensibilities and care your
sensibilities about simplicity being
equal to ease of use are wrong they're
just simply wrong right we saw the
definitions of simple and easy they're
completely different things
right so easy is not simple
you have to start developing
sensibilities around entanglement that's
what you have to just you have to have
entanglement radar
right you want to look at some software
and say ah
you know not that i don't like the names
you used or the shape of the code or
there was a semicolon i mean that's also
important too but you want to start
seeing complecting you want to start
seeing interconnections between things
that could be independent that's where
you're going to get the most power
all the reliability tools you have
right since they're not about simplicity
they're all secondary
right they just do not touch the core of
this problem
right they're safety nets
but they're nothing more than that
so
how do we make simplicity easy
right
we're going to choose constructs with
simpler
artifacts right and avoid constructs
that have complex artifacts
it's the artifacts
it's not the authoring as soon as you
get an argument with somebody about oh
should we should be using whatever get
that sorted out
you know because however they feel about
the shape of the code they type in is
independent from this and this is the
thing you have to live with
we're going to try to create
abstractions that have simplicity as a
basis
right
we're going to spend a little time up
front
simplifying things
before we get started
and recognize that when you simplify
things you often end up with more things
right simplicity is not about counting
right i'd have rather have more things
hanging nice straight down not twisted
together
than just a couple of things tied in a
knot
and the beautiful thing about making
them separate is you'll have a lot more
ability to change it which is where i
think the benefits lie
so
i think this is a big deal
and
i hope everybody's able to bring it into
practice or use this as a tool for
convincing somebody else to do that
so i'll leave you with this
this is what you say when somebody
tries to sell you a sophisticated type
system
thank you
you